vous avez la responsabilité politique et humanitaire
d'utiliser immédiatement
ces capacités dans les pays touchés par Ebola
pour freiner l'épidémie il est
impératif que l'État
déploie immédiatement des ressources civiles et militaires
ayant une expertise dans le confinement des risques biologiques
cela devrait être fait en étroite
collaboration avec les
pays touchés sans cela  déploiement nous
ne maîtriserons jamais l'
épidémie asseyez-vous à une note sur le milquetoast
la valeur que les nouvelles coopératives ont bien au-dessus des
masses s'offrir un médecin quand vous avez joué
une favela victime de laboulaye un
manque bizarre de rente aide internationale pour
le jet Alperin s  à Lisbonne dans la terreur à
Alesia le droit disco Ian électro tourné
Polly quelques dimanches à connecter et Kalka
sermon dr.  La confiance de Luka sur les pâtes
conduit principalement le passage amore Les
pores de l'anatomie de ce que le courrier m'a ordonné de lire
ceci sur l'université alma mater les
vues sur la tortue vous mrs.  Robison aha
Trevor Villa
pas fiançailles couleur commentateur
nationalité victime écoutez encore T le
tornavoz wah
Kelly Marcel n'a même pas beaucoup de procédure
18 organes Assam à juste particulièrement
Jennifer intervient à Abuja P moi
assis va à contre le son pourrait être
jamais me voir ouais le  BG dit que la
responsabilité de Nomar, allez sur Casper, concentrez-vous sur
jusqu'à ce que l'arabasadi de ma mère me rende mes
paramètres de motel sur les masses, donc
encore une fois, ce n'est pas le but merci, oui,
pourquoi remercier Karen, merci, la clé de monopole que
Trevino a mise sur ce PE, une oreille s'il vous plaît,
kappa se prépare pour le soleil pasanda  sait l'
action alors maintenant ils paient l'année complète
ne nous n'étions pas en place mais la base réelle
suka voir voir ii / kk me montre avec chaque
ville de Pascoe de manière durable accomplie de manière
polaire Cal Spas capitate et supposons que nous
disons aussi l'inverse de Cerro San Jose  San
Justine vient un podiatre facilement vient d'
arriver à Ellis once pour vous
l'air imminent fédéral les
participants et quelques polices ouais
attends attends adolescent damocles  existence
sentir le prélèvement de salsa elle me laisse cet
imamat circuité correct meta sophomore
partager lady sapele Lepidoptera Schmidt
manière émotionnelle eh bien c'est un
canon botanique me voir efficacement Canada
m'encanta Québec parce que tu mets la
personnalité sur les coupeurs de moulin en bas du
prélèvement sexuel un contacté EuroNCAP re
utilisez à tout moment dès qu'une alarme externe
écoutez dans une lampe le visage de Joanna le
gouvernement comme une crèche pas à propos de plomb
Emma Jean le bola peut vraiment devenir
affligé vous ne savez pas libéral une base d'
accord le club de lecture comme Christopher première
soirée soeur Polly bola ne le faites pas  couchez-vous en
dessous Josie et l'unité m'a
embrassé le mur République Démocratique du
Congo Deepika moi avec le milieu est l'esprit
il a approuvé le procès-verbal déballer l'
effet de sentiment un moi faire du personnel cette annonce une
mine d'argent stress âne X virgule X
virgule un compte clé retour à l'école
Chaudhary bleu  Dakota Kallenbach sonne
comme une nouvelle voix sur la voiture le
modèle pysanky une communauté demande l'importance exa
dit passé tuer dire avec un  condo sur la
photographie complète la personne DPD mucho
360 Allah
un pauvre nanano certains développe une faculté
une communauté de verrouillage Christina
vous choisissez le Mamaki la téléprésence
active est le Tyvek profite de tout
ordinateur portable nocif Agassi sur moi passé vient un peu
avec aquel caso le CLR maintenant  voir aquel
kazoo laissez-moi rencontrer le déploiement serré de toutes les
difficultés sur la communauté Nelly
un restaurant à l'échelle nationale Corinth ouvre la foire
sur un gars donc non tu viens avec des
épouses profondes wa ma la parka Savannah mother
shaker Japon scandaleux donk sur un parc
jusqu'à Jana s'il te plait fais du lait  du tout le lait
n'est pas un chiffre mensuel dû aux commandes mystiques de l'Allemagne
[ __ ] et une communauté est comme
une communauté terminale c'est seulement extra mon
papa
k la communauté n'a pas besoin de
défaut isopropyl la réponse le bola
OS Audrey Hawaii parousie sur Auckland
surtout poster à un national  la milice
Copeland poker est apparue Olga sis millions de
packs sur l'avocat contraint Ravi Kumasi
esta développer sur L Ebola cartilage o-tar
faire alors sur l'AG vraiment  gosse le Diplôme
genou le paludisme frapper lésions ce cm
problème est une colonne Tommy problème de chien
bien Cecil important dodo de quelques colonnes
méchamment privé un processus pour Alicia pour
indemnisation des
recenseurs de préoccupation de parcimonie Dépôt vous
rappeler Kelly dos attaque sur Lulu Booton
Booya Quechua a  sur un sur un diligent
entre les porcs à l'apparition de
ce serait d'avertir du revers appliquer le
les porcs a sur s'il vous plaît tous fait ce spectacle
pâturage ologie ils ont mis celui-ci c'est
un lundi un autre son le
poète de transition et Volta
Oh professeur Pitino  le son est une amande à
propos de la communauté de verrouillage du besoin le plus cher mal répété
LF Amérique même développeur
Canada inconnu Je crois que Xiao Yi en a
mis en personne non c'est X n'a ​​besoin que de
contacter dans le contact le continent asiatique de contact
s'il vous plaît soyez Cariah
l'arrestation du bureau d'évasion qui en résulte comme
ses artistes de représentation  coup comparable donc
comme son arrêt de cavité de liqueurs Dimitra e
sur le communautarisme autonomie gracias compadre
seulement par seconde un problème  em travaillent
bien sur mon analyse du caucus un Maxim
nous-mêmes un ascenseur afin que les ressources que
vous pouvez affecter jusqu'à ce que nous voyons généralement le public
comme un autre argent que nous voyons sous un
sedima compact et agréable au goût
augmenter le dollar que vous venez à joshua
semble assez génial ce million
pysanky neige réfugié le million
Dmytro yarosh algérie aux loisirs
omar al colossal au milieu des
calculs de Stéphanie les gens ont seulement dit que
je savais sur un message téléphonique de pedo bertocchi
c'est éteint - mmm c'est Stéphanie sur ils ont
épelé je me souviens de le définir un
appelant masculin vous savez que c'est dans un  recevoir le
nom d'une vidéo et devenir comme un an
jusqu'à présent attendez attendez vous désarmez un novice politique
lomotil conseille le populisme la plupart des
participants alors polygraphiste banquier nommé
Juliana a immigré misérables médecins
pas politiquement ou si naturellement
Tzenkethi Sanusi pourtant moi que se lama
usted necesita male  l'agent immobilier sait que l'
affaire n'est pas à la hauteur des Italiens
à propos de Denis una mano jacoba Tokyo a modifié l'
immigrant permet à DC de venir voir Audre  y est une
ambulance marocaine reste occasionnelle un
Pathan avec André dans parmi les gramma
réserve
immaculée I pour résoudre un problème Papa
Allah o TM problème un comportement polymathique
généralement pour la charité
le criminel est un laïc chef époque
personne avertie
futur c'était la gravité gmail est Alicia a I  'd
me laisser
Willie réfugiés pour parler de nous ainsi que
l'initiative calculée pour assez
expansive de Billa autour de
mesures réelles du président du continent,
sachez simplement qu'Allah m'aime lire Phyllis -
ah merci beaucoup beaucoup a choisi n'importe quel
candidat qui était rempli d'une politique
[Rires]
merci  beaucoup de vous dire qu'on en verra peut être
commander la tulipe en Europe